[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
honestly ever since my son
has come in my life i don't sweat the
little things as much
because i have to set an example for him
people really thought i had a great year
last year what continues to drive me is
knowing i have so much room to improve
things like the most improved player
award all that just shows
you you know you're dedicated to hard
work so i think just scratching the
surface
this was a culmination of years and
years of dedication and hard work and
mental fortitude
next accolade mvp man i think that would
be fitting i think the ultimate goal is
just bringing a championship to the city
of new york so that's really what drives
me every day
i studied everything about code growing
up when i got
to la as a rich i was really excited
just to practice with him and you know
he called me up
5am 6am bringing me all the way out to
orange county and we're working out
and just to have that example and to be
able to ask questions
to a basketball genius like what more
could i ask for one of the things i
really learned from kobe was if you go
into the summer and there's things that
you want to improve on
focus on one or two things that's what i
did last time i was very specific about
how i wanted to get better
and i'm doing the same thing this year
footwork and finishing at the rim
littlest things can make the biggest
difference
tibbs is absolutely amazing bro like who
he is
as a coach who he is as a person to his
core
all he cares about is putting players in
the best spot to win the game
i've never seen a coach work harder
there would be times where i'd go into
the gym nine o'clock at night and tibs
is still there
studying watching film he always tells
me the best form of leadership that you
can give is the example that you set for
others
that's really my strong suit whether
it's early in the gym late in the gym
putting a little extra workout we would
say that's true leadership not just
bringing the best out of yourself but
bringing the best out of others
i feel like i've always had that drive a
lot of it comes from
people that i've looked to my idols
growing up whether it's my mom just
seeing how hard she worked on a
day-to-day basis to provide for my
sister or not
my mom she was definitely uh hard on me
i have an older sister i used to play
one of my best friends just play two and
two all the time and they used to kick
our butt man and it would truly upset me
to where i would be in tears
honestly it was a great lesson as a kid
about determination and just pure will
and as i get older i have my son it's
given me a total
new perspective before he came in my
life the 21 22 year old me
if i have a bad game it might be the end
of the world like
you know i see so much of myself and him
for instance he hates the loops
absolutely hates it my wife is concerned
sometimes and i'm just trying to teach
him like life lessons like let that
motivate you
to be better let that motivate you be
the best version of you
he loves basketball and i don't even
push it on he's literally picking up on
everything he picks the ball
up and he does his shimmy and then he
shoots
and i'm like what are you doing you
watch trey young do it like he makes a
long shot he goes kite in for three
and then he these chests and kisses at
the sky and i'm like who does that
steph curry does this so it's just
little things like that
something a fan might learn about me and
be shocked
uh i'm a really good cook i've been
cooking since
like 10 11 years old a lot of that was
because my mom would be working late at
night
and me and my sister and we have to
figure it out so
my favorite dish is chicken alfredo i
can do southern foods i'm a southern boy
so whatever you name
every time i land in the city before you
do anything i have the team set up a gym
for me to go to
just to get a little work in just to
feel the ball keeps me in a constant
rhythm keeps me locked in and just keeps
me sharp
this is the first time i've ever had a
team that they all came with me
now we have the whole team bus taking us
to the gym because
everybody on the team wants to go and
get extra shots of your extra work
and i think it just became a part of the
identity of our team that we just won't
be our work